die leute was geht ich hoffe euch geht
es gut mal klappt man hier den
bildschirm umsonst ob ich da viel zu
viel rein
back to the roots sage ich mal
ich weiß nicht an die die schon länger
dabei sind ihr wird wahrscheinlich
dieses video location noch können ich
bin meinem alten zimmer früher hat alles
ist irgendwie so hier angefangen
das ist manchmal auf meinem bett saß
manchmal stand ich brauche jetzt im
schrank dahinter noch so ein bild ich
hatte hier so eine kleine aufnahme ecke
dann bin ich nach köln gezogen habe
dieses bett wo kaufe ich jetzt sitze
mitgenommen nach köln das stand dann da
habe ich mir irgendwann neues bett
gekauft dann haben dass meine eltern
wieder hier hingestellt also dieses bild
ist schon sehr viel rumgekommen war
schon mal in köln
und ich hab einfach auf diesem bett
damals da ist ja auch egal
auf jeden fall denn ihr euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich was labert ja gerade
es wird am mont aker und es wird auch
glaube ich wirklich dass unauffälligste
video ever aber es wird ein
interessantes video für mich auf jeden
fall weil ich habe mich jetzt dazu
entschlossen million zu setzen und ja
das zu machen einfach weil ich finde das
lohnt sich also es ist auf jeden fall
eine zeit das zu tun und das ist jetzt
auch nicht spektakuläre sondern trotzdem
würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn ihr das
wenn wir dran bleibt wenn ihr ab und zu
werden wenn meine videos schaut und dann
auch nach dem video
eure meinung dazu sagten so empfangen
wir mal ganz von vorne an
oder von vorne zumindest jetzt dieses
thema wenn man dieses fest ist schwierig
jetzt kann ich gar nicht schneiden wir
fangen ganz von vorne an wo dieses
kapitel begann was gar nicht mal so
lange her ist etwas über zwei monate und
zwar saß ich da und habe mir so überlegt
sodann youtube kanal läuft zwar an sich
aber ist es nicht mehr so ist er
wirklich so ein richtiges konzept und so
eine richtige leidenschaft dahinter sag
ich mal
und ich habe mir als ziel gesetzt mich
wieder mehr darum zu kümmern und habe
dann gesagt du machst jetzt einfach mal
daily das ist möglich sich jeden tag
hinzusetzen videos zu drehen videos zu
schneiden
man kann an einem tag manchmal vier
videos von videos drehen und die dann
auch halt schneiden
ich habe juli dazu geholt
der mir auch beim schneiden hilft und
wir haben gesagt wir wollen jetzt
einfach mal die raus wir schreiben alle
ideen auf die ich habe und dann geht's
los und man muss auch sagen ich habe das
bis jetzt hinbekommen bis auf einen tag
glaube ich da kann kein video oder zwei
tage sonst gab es jeden tag ein video
obwohl ich zweimal für längere zeit weg
musste und wir vor produzieren mussten
und so weiter und so fort
und man kann auch sagen wir haben ist
leider nicht geschafft noch weiter fort
zu produzieren also dass ich zum
beispiel jetzt die nächsten dreißig
videos schon alles fertig habt was wir
hätten schaffen können auf jeden fall
weil man kann so richtig produktiv sein
sage ich mal so und ich habe auch
gemerkt dass so in dieser zeit wieder
haben wieder so eine coole community
entstanden ist die sich immer für die
sachen interessieren immer die gleichen
leute schon zurückliegt ist extrem für
den nachrichten beiden zu können und so
weiter worüber ich mich sehr freue
also es geht auf jeden fall eine
richtige richtung weil ich davor so ein
bisschen das gefühl hatte das konzept
von einem kanal gelegen so ein bisschen
so ich weiß nicht ich habe mich selber
nicht mehr so ganz wieder erkannt sagt
mal so
deswegen erstmal großes dankeschön dafür
an alle die ab und zu mal die videos
schauen
ich freue mich sehr darüber und was ich
was was also es macht mir wieder so
richtig spaß
sag ich mal weil früher muss ich ganz
klar sagen habe ich immer ich habe mich
so hingesetzt und habe überlegt welches
video könnte jetzt gerade zu dieser zeit
abgehen so was könnte so richtig einheit
generieren und hat es dann gemacht
obwohl es gar nicht mal unbedingt so
viel spaß gemacht hat also man ist immer
so ein bisschen so nach klicks gegangen
was könnte jetzt gut abgehen und was
nicht und dadurch dass ich jetzt daily
produziere ich kann alles machen worauf
ich bock hab so viel ja auch wenn ich
weiß ihr könnt wahrscheinlich manche von
euch diese videos wo ich so essens boxen
auspacken
das würde ich wahrscheinlich niemals tun
wenn ich jetzt immer nur videos haben
möchte die viele leute schauen weil das
sind zum beispiel videos die kommen
nicht so gut an machen mir war extrem
viel spaß und deswegen mache ich die und
da ist es auch gar nicht schlimm wenn
das video dann noch ein bisschen
untergeht ich habe es trotzdem gemacht
und es gibt immer leute die
dafür interessieren und das hat mir spaß
gemacht und das ist ja eigentlich das
wichtigste darum sollte es auch gehen
natürlich ist es bei mir dann leider
auch so dass ich davon immer meinen
lebensunterhalt finanzieren muss und so
sonst würde ich wahrscheinlich noch
andere projekte machen oder ich weiß
nicht das ist natürlich immer so eine
kleine sonne sondern so ein faktor der
damit einfließt aber ich kann alles
super stimme und finanzieren und genau
aber man muss natürlich auch immer so
ein bisschen gucken wie kommt man über
die runden weil ich natürlich auch noch
studieren und aber auch meinen youtube
kanal habe mit dem ich praktisch mein
ganzes leben finanzieren
es kommen jetzt in zukunft noch ein zwei
projekte
das könnte richtig heiß werden und auch
gerade für juli also juli heute der mann
verfilmt meist fast immer eigentlich
immer filmt wir wollen uns da so
nebenbei so ein bisschen was aufbauen
und da gibt es auch noch ein paar infos
für euch und es wird cool ich sage mal
so man kann es vielleicht so
zusammenfassen
wir wollen unser eigenes machen
beziehungsweise in eigenem shop so
richtig aufziehen
allerdings ganz anders als man es kennt
also nicht auf nicht auf masse sondern
auf witzig unterhaltsam ist schwierig zu
erklären also da gibt's hier hinten zu
und warum ich dieses video jetzt mache
ist um in erster linie mal danke zu
sagen für für die zeit jetzt die wir
hatten und die ganzen videos und dass es
mir so viel spaß gemacht hat auf der
anderen seite aber auch weil ist sehr
sehr wichtig ist von mir von euch zu
hören oder von euch eure meinung zu
hören weil ich auch oft lese jo du hast
jetzt schon so auf das gemacht macht
auch mal wieder was anderes und so und
zum was ist als dritter punkt noch
hinzukommt ich habe jetzt zwei drei
monate mich total auf essens videos
konzentriert auspackt videos die sind
alle super entspannt und sind auch
wieder neue leute auf meinen kanal
gekommen die sich genau für so etwas
interessieren
und jetzt zum beispiel was mir so ein
bisschen ich weiß nicht ob ich sagen das
macht mir sorge es ist halt nur auf
jeden fall in meinem kopf ich habe bei
kreisklassen bad mitgespielt
und das war auch eine supercoole zeit
und ich hatte auch mal wieder richtig
bock einfach auf einem kanal so so
reaktions videos raus zu ballern auf die
folgen oder man blog hochzuladen und
euch zu zeigen und das ist dann ja
wieder komplett anderer content also an
die dieses kreisklassen dran die das
gras klassenfahrten und ich kenne das
ist so eine youtube serie mit ganz
vielen anderen youtube
ja das ist dann halt wieder total
anderer content und da denke ich sondern
so wieder ist das jetzt gut für dein
kanal weil es ist ja schon wichtig dass
man sich so auf einen themengebiet
fokussiert und halt so in dieser
richtung dann auch bleibt und nicht hier
was macht jeweils man hier was macht
hier was macht und deswegen habe ich
gelacht setzte sich einfach mal hin
redest so ein bisschen so persönlich was
rat so deine gedanken sind mit meinen
zuschauern und fragt einfach mal weil es
mir immer super wichtig ist was eure
ideen und anregungen sind
ich setze ja auch viele sachen um die
hälfte meiner videos entstehen alle mit
euren ideen um einfach jetzt mal so von
euch zu hören sein tier das wie ich das
jetzt in den letzten zwei monaten
gemacht habe oder gibt es auch sachen
wohl sagt ey das hätte ich mal anders
gemacht oder sowas könntest du doch auch
noch machen das passt doch richtig gut
rein und da ist es mir ganz ganz wichtig
jetzt nicht so kommentare zu lesen
mach doch mal wieder 24 stunden burger
kinder essen da denke ich mir so also
solche leute oder solcher konnte hat
halt auf einem kanal finde ich nichts
mehr verloren weil das einfach so träsch
scheiße ist und damit werde ich mich gar
nicht auseinandersetzen
ja also das hat man auch gemerkt durch
diese zeit ist durch die letzten zwei
monate sind meine zuschauer auch ein
bisschen älter geworden und es sind
viele leute dazugekommen die ein
bisschen älter sind dass man sich gerade
von den ganzen nachrichtendienst bekomme
was mich auch sehr erfreut weil ich ja
auch nicht immer werde ja also schreibt
super gerne eure meinung in die
kommentare
eure anregungen und was euch vielleicht
wenn es um einen kanal gilt in den kopf
kommt und ob wie und ob ihr euch
trotzdem so über auch mal wieder so ein
paar
andere sachen wie früher so reaktionen
lover videos freuen würde weil das mache
ich ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr
ja das war es auch eigentlich schon mit
dem was ich was ich mir hier von wie
sagt man so schön von der seele reden
wollte und ich hoffe dass viele von euch
was jetzt dran geblieben sind und ist
auch interessant fanden ja ansonsten ich
freue mich richtig auf die zukunft ich
freue mich verdammt krass ich habe jetzt
noch wenn jetzt am sonntag spielen wir
haben sie nach berlin weil da wieder was
von kreisklassen hat anständig freue
mich die ganzen leute wiederzusehen
dann darf ich noch bei einem kinofilm
wird kleine rolle spielen freue mich
auch richtig drauf dann noch weitere
projekte die diesen kanal betreffen und
auch ein weiteres projekt sich mal
wieder von von ganz 0 bis etwas weiter
nach oben aus aufzubauen so wie ich
damals in meinem youtube-kanal gemacht
habe ich hoffe das klappt auch und dann
ist alles gut
ja danke fürs zuhören und wir sehen uns
morgen 19 uhr
da gibt es dann wieder normales video
und morgen kommt ein geiles bio weil das
video war ich auf jeden fall machen da
hatte ich richtig lust drauf ich kann ja
jetzt schon mal sagen worum es geht und
zwar habe ich ja damals beim pizza
lieferservice fünfmal hintereinander
bestellt und so und morgen kommt ein
video
da habe ich bei acht verschiedenen
pizzerien gleichzeitig gestellt und die
kamen dann also sollte ich das sehr
gerne an wolf doch das war es von mir
instagram alex w danke ich freue mich
immer wieder hoch zu laden was ich
weiter anschauen und das ist das
wichtigste für mich